robert george who's the moral professor
of professor of moral philosophy
over at princeton he says he uses this
as a sort of thought experiment he says
okay so he'll ask his class
you're living in 1860 in alabama are you
an abolitionist or are you pro-slavery
and everybody in the room
everyone says i'm an abolitionist and
then he's like really really are you
because i'd love for you to name these
extremely unpopular positions you're
taking at the risk to your life
reputation and career
right now today like it actually risks
anything because none of you can name
any of them right
you're actually going along to get along
with most of your morality the example
that i like to use on this
is we're living in an era where
everybody thinks of themselves as as
deeply enlightened and all of this
a hundred years from now all these all
the statues of president obama will come
down why because he ate mead
a hundred years from now all the statues
of president obama will come down
because there's video of him
at campaign rallies you know in iowa
campaign stops eating a corn dog
[Music]
let's pause there for a second because
we're dealing with this canceled
cultured nonsense
right now do you think that there is
just a certain inertia
to movements like cancel culture because
of
because of all of the stuff that we
started this conversation talking about
that it's like we've had this thing
slowly building but now it does feel
like it hit the tipping point and now
it's just spread everywhere
do you think there's like a functional
reason for that yeah i mean i think that
there have been decades of an attempt to
rethink what rights actually mean
so one of the things that the left has
done is in the same way that we started
off by talking about the redefinition of
racism
they've redefined nearly every term that
we've talked about here
they've redefined every element of
american philosophy to mean almost the
precise reverse of what originally was
meant to me
they've redefined virtually all of
american history which is what the 1619
project is about
and they've redefined our culture of
rights so that rights are in fact
ways to oppress people right this is
when when we talked a little bit earlier
about the right to free speech being
seen as a way for the powerful to
silence the powerless and you see people
actually saying this kind of stuff it's
crazy i mean this is
in effect what right white fragility is
about this is effect what all of the
the whole blm platform this is what it
is about like you're not just making
this stuff up no i mean
and when i wrote the book i didn't
realize that it was going to break into
the open this way
i really thought that honestly when
coveted hit in march i thought okay i
wrote this book to rush out before the
election and now it's going to be
irrelevant because it's all going to be
coveted all the time
and then all this stuff just broke loose
in the last couple of months and i
thought
wow i mean i'm not a prophet but if i
were but
but that that's really how it feels i
mean looking back through the book
and realizing that all the arguments
that i was making against this
particular vision of america which i
call disintegrationist and the reason i
call disintegrationist
is because i think that it really stands
for the the coming apart of america
i think that there's a group of people
who say here are all the things we have
in common and as lincoln said
we have to be brothers because if we're
not brothers we're going to be enemies
right that's that's just how this is
going to be the better angels of our
nature
had better win and we better all be on
the same page or we're going to fall
apart i think there's a group of people
who believe that they are the sole
exposers of ultimate truth
and as the sole expositors of ultimate
truth they get to club everybody else
into submission and therefore all of the
checks and balances should go away
because they are now the god-like
leaders
who know all the wisdom of the ages
they're the best people who have ever
lived
i mean this is the impression yeah
incredible that they're it's
unbelievable
everyone that came here what what lucky
people we are to be living in this time
this time
with such unbelievably special people
right who gets to rip down statues of
ulysses s grant and who get to suggest
that abraham lincoln was a bad man
whereas they
they would if they had been living in
1863 they wouldn't have just been
abolitionists
they would have been people who are
arguing for for all end to segregation
and
and complete mixing of people of
different races like
all the principles they hold today that
are good principles right all those
principles they would have held them
doubtless in 1863 with no background in
any of this stuff if they had been born
all of their values are sort of floating
miasmatically in the atmosphere
and they internalized them and they
would have been if it wouldn't matter
you could have plopped them down
in rome in in 100 bc and they would have
held exactly the same values they exist
outside of time
they exist outside of history they exist
absent any other outside influences
they're just the most incredible people
who have ever lived in the history of
humanity good for them i mean and good
for us that we get to live
at a time of such things it's so
interesting because i've been thinking
about this a lot like if you think about
how fast it seems the world is moving
right now like just think about today
versus just
what we were talking about say 10 years
ago in 2010 whatever the hell it was
now if you take that further back and
you pop that person down in 1863
and try to imagine how different the
world is like people don't really just
sit in that for a minute
and realize how different it was without
plumbing and electricity and all of
those things
and yet somehow their entire moral code
would have been
you know which they make up it would be
exactly the same
they're not standing on the shoulders of
giants they didn't learn anything from
lincoln american history has nothing to
do with their positions
they exist as free-floating moral actors
in the universe without any background
whatsoever they came to all of the
exact right conclusions about life
simply through a priori thinking
it's it's truly an unbelievable
achievement of the human mind i think
again we should we should all feel
very lucky to be in their presence of
course this is all [ __ ] i mean the
fact is
robert george who's the moral professor
of professor of moral philosophy over at
princeton
he says he uses this as a sort of
thought experiment he says okay so he'll
ask his class
you're living in 1860 in alabama are you
an abolitionist or are you pro-slavery
and everybody in the room
everyone says i'm an abolitionist and
then he's like really really are you
because i'd love for you to name these
extremely unpopular position you're
taking at the risk to your life
reputation and career
right now today like it actually risks
anything because none of you can name
any of them right
you're actually going along to get along
with most of your morality the example
that i like to use on this
is we're living in an era where
everybody thinks of themselves as as
deeply enlightened and all of this
100 years from now all these all the
statues of president obama will come
down why because he ate made
100 years from now all the statues of
president obama will come down because
there's video of him
at campaign rallies you know in iowa
campaign stops eating a corn dog he had
that hot dog right and
people are going to say
it's the next frontier of this lunacy
and and what's going to happen is it's
going to be
there were people who knew back then
that this was being mean to animals and
you ignored that sort of that sort of
suffering
that means animals it's also destroying
the environment right it's just right
right you drove a car i mean there were
people who weren't driving cars you
can't say that you were completely
innocent in all of this
nobody is completely innocent in all
this the reason that we erect monuments
to people is for the good stuff they did
not the bad stuff they did
um but again when you think of yourself
as better than any human being who has
ever lived it gives you an awful lot of
moral authority to rip down everything
around you right so okay so we've we've
sort of veered into chapter two here was
which is when you talk about that
disintegration do you think that once
something
starts disintegrating at a certain rate
that then it's inevitable that it
will disintegrate because and that's
sort of what we're i think a lot of
people are feeling that right now like
oh my god the world really has shifted
the conversation has shifted
it feels like everything's out of
control
can it actually you know if the wave has
started can you actually turn the wave
around i mean i think the only way to
really turn the wave around is to
re-familiarize ourselves with principles
which is a difficult
task i mean we've we've basically
assumed that freedom was in the water
for 50 years 60 years and it turns out
freedom was not in the water kool-aid
was in the water
and people have been drinking into
university campuses and they've been
reading howard's in for a while
and now they think they have a very
sophisticated view of the world and and
so it takes
some some education in american history
and american philosophy
to really re-inculcate that but that's a
hard that's a hard slog i think it's
gonna be a rough time here i
don't think this is gonna i think
there's this assumption on the part of
liberals like good-hearted liberals who
actually believe a lot of the stuff in
the book because this is not partisan
right
i really believe that everything that
i've said about american history and
american culture like rights are good
and the declaration of independence all
human beings are equal before the law
like this should be pretty consensus
stuff i mean this is not right left or
centered
i know a lot of liberals who agree with
this yeah but i think that there's this
assumption that because everything is
trump polarized that if biden is elected
that all this sort of goes back to
normal everybody calms down
it goes away i think they are really
underestimating an ascendant left that
sees
the that sees the wave of history behind
them and they also see a weak actor in
joe biden they feel like they can push
him around and i think they're probably
right about that
i mean the guy's got serious problems
it's like that's the scandal
right like isn't that the scandal that
no one will talk about the scandal which
is that obviously something's wrong with
him
i mean it's it is pretty incredible that
that's considered such an out of balance
opinion i mean
being like how did without any evidence
you're suggesting that he's on the verge
of senility i mean i don't watch the
tape of him like eight years ago and
then watch the tape of him today and
joe biden was never any great shakes but
he looks like a different dude i mean
and and listen
you can elect them if you want i mean
that's that's your prerogative all right
but recognize that there's a high
likelihood you're also electing as vice
president
right so okay so we we started talking
about culture and i wanted to pause you
in the middle of it because when we talk
about culture
ben someone's gonna say you're talking
about american culture that's chapter
three but
american culture must mean white culture
that's what you really mean
shapiro is that it's about white culture
right and this this goes back to this
whole
anti-racist idea which is that rights
themselves are a vestige of a white
supremacist system which
ignores all of the progress not only
made by black people but made by black
people
in the name of right in the name of
rights martin luther king saying
we ought to have the same freedoms that
you all are guaranteed
our freedom of speech matters no less
than your freedom of speech an american
is saying
because you're making that argument not
the argument the entire system is bad
not the sort of early malcolm x argument
that white people are devils and the
entire system is garbage and all of this
the stuff that he abandoned later in his
career
you know because you're making the
actual american argument
yeah we'll give that we'll give that a
hearing that makes that makes sense to
us right i mean this is the argument
again being made by frederick douglass
he wasn't saying
that july 4th is bad he's saying we're
not included in that promise we should
be included in that promise
when you invoke the deep principles of
america you're like
your movement is likely to see victory
right this is the same thing that
happened with the gay rights movement
the gay rights movement said listen
you guys are guaranteed freedom of
association you're guaranteed freedom in
who you love right so it was a rights
argument now i may not have agreed with
the application with regard to behavior
but
the the actual rights with regard to
marriage with the actual
early argument which was everybody
should basically be left alone that was
a very
robust argument it had a lot of power
behind it because most americans went
yeah that makes sense to me i mean i
have that kind of freedom why shouldn't
that guy have that kind of freedom like
why not
yeah right which is a different argument
than some of the arguments we're now
having which have moved beyond the
rubric of rights into
well i can demand from you a good or
service i can write that that's a bit of
a different thing
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell